Shadow Hills actually we're streeting
where there's no that number is going to
go off extraordinary I mean
we've got the Absurd spectacle today of
the Prime Minister and other government
ministers celebrating the 75th
anniversary of an institution they have
broken and the fact is Rishi sunak when
he became conservative party leader he
said he would cut waiting lists and they
are rising and they are continuing to
rise
and today he's I think looking to blame
NHS staff he's saying oh I'm going to
really struggle to get these NHS waiting
lists down because NHS staff are out on
strike and then you look at what Rishi
sunaka's prime minister well it is but
you know Rishi sunak has taken the same
degree of action on NHS strikes that
he's taken on the Australians foul play
at the cricket which is to say oh this
is this is terrible what's he actually
doing when was the last time he got the
junior doctors or the Consultants or
even the nurses for that matter around
the table to negotiate and enter this
dispute he he acts as if he's a
commentator
I think he's got to knock some heads
together I think his health secretary is
failing to negotiate and enter these
strikes I think they are badly
underestimated the degree of palpable
anger in the NHS Workforce not just
about their pay but actually about their
patience and about the conditions
they're working in they're slogging
their guts out and they know that
patients aren't getting good enough care
through no fault of their own and they
are desperate for some light at the end
of the tunnel and the Prime Minister
isn't providing it he's acting as a
commentator rather than a leader
and and we've got to resolve the NHS
strikes but we've also got to make sure
that in particularly this 75th
anniversary of the NHS that we've got a
future to look forward to of both
investment and reform to deliver the
change of modernization the NHS needs to
be fit for the next 75 years because at
the moment the NHS is in Jeopardy I'm
anxious about the future of the NHS as I
think the rest of the country is and
unless it changes it will die and yet
the NHS founding principles Public
Service free at the point of use there
for us when we need it is absolutely
possible for the next 75 years but it
needs the right leadership of course I
would argue a change of leadership a
change of government uh former labor
prime minister as you know Tony Blair
suggesting that some people should pay
to use the NHS I I don't agree with that
I mean I think we've already got a
two-tier system in this country where
people who can afford it paying to go
private and those who can't are being
left behind in fact that's one of the
reasons I've said are not
uncontroversially that if their spare
capacity in the private sector we will
pay for people to use it on NHS terms
free at the point of view so they don't
pay a penny where I want to get to if
I'm the country's next Health secretary
is an NHS that's so good that no one
feels forced to go private because
that's what the last Labor government
did ironically you know use of the
private sector fell off a cliff after 13
years because we delivered the shortest
waiting times and the highest patient
satisfaction history so of course people
said well why would I go private the NHS
is there for me when I need it okay so
you completely disagree with your Tony
Blair is suggesting that people who can
afford to pay should do that in order
for uh to free up capacity for others I
do because I think that an NHS that's
publicly funded free at the point of use
is the fairest and most efficient way to
organize a system and if we if you're
wealthy and have the ability to pay more
then the tax system can do that very
efficiently and effectively and when you
look at Labor's policies I mean we're
not if you know we've taken some Flack
for this but I think we have rightly not
made loads and loads of spending
commitments because we know the Public
Finance are in a mess where we have made
spending commitments we have gone for
fair sources of raising the money like
abolishing the non-dom tax status
because we think wealthy people who make
Britain their home should pay their
taxes here too so I do disagree with
Tony Blair on that he's got some other
interesting ideas he's put out today
about how we can use data and Technology
more effectively to give people really
personal Health Service to organize
resources in the system more efficiently
and effectively and to liberate the poor
NHS Workforce from the creaking I.T
systems that make their everyday work
and productivity an absolute misery and
you know patients can see it too haven't
you know how many of us have had a
letter in the post telling us that our
appointment is canceled the the day
after we turned up for it we've got got
plenty of examples of the way in which
we see the NHS inefficiency and I think
there's something in that but the idea
that we would pay for the NHS through
user charging I mean Over My Dead Body
frankly and there are plenty of
conservatives who are making that
argument at the moment I I will not
compromise on the principle of an NHS
that's free at the point of use and to
be fair the health Minister said that as
well uh speaking of people with plenty
money Coots the private
in order to have an account with them
you need to have three million pounds
deposited oh no that's that's me priced
out
and they say that's why and Nigel farage
does no longer have an account with them
um we've heard the chances like at my
world's smallest violin out for Nigel
farage not getting his cute second you
can Bank in that West or HSBC like the
rest of us might do sorry do you have
any sympathy though for I mean he's
suggesting it's a it's about free speech
and to be honest I literally do not care
about this topic I mean no I always like
to come on your program answer questions
I literally could not care less about
about Nigel farage's banking
Arrangements I do care about the people
who can't afford their mortgages or
can't afford their rents or get into the
end of the month and are in their
overdraft because they've got more bills
to pay and they've got money coming in
that's most people's experience but
Nigel if you're watching I'm I'm very
sorry but I will be shedding no tears
about you not having three million
pounds to deposit and it keeps spanking
but it goes to a wider subject a wider
point which is he says eight banks have
said that you can't have an account and
he says it's because of his political
beliefs people should be able to bank
even if you don't agree with what
they're saying yeah I think that's a
different issue if people are being
discriminated against
in terms of their banking because of
their political views well that's a
different kettle of fish and actually
there I would say despite strongly
disagreeing with him on pretty much
everything
um that would not be appropriate for him
or anyone else actually but um but yeah
I must say I literally don't care about
Nigel farage's bank accounts I'm sorry
what you do care about very briefly is
your new book it's got a funky title
one boy two bills and a fry up tell me
why um one boy is me two bills of my
very different Grandad's one very
straight lace pull yourself up by a
bootstraps working class Tory the other
an arm robber is in and out of prison
throughout his child my mum's child of
my childhood
um very different characters and the fry
up is literally the fry up that saved my
life because my mum was due to have an
abortion she was 18 when she was
pregnant with me the appointment was
booked she decided not to go through
with it so on the day of the termination
she did what she was told explicitly she
could not do which was have breakfast
she cooked herself a fry up and that way
she couldn't be frog marched down to the
hospital by my nan he was absolutely
apoplectic that her daughter was having
a baby and I sort of understand given
that I'm 40 my nan was 41 when I was
born and I can understand why as a 41
year old woman she didn't necessarily
want a grandchild even though she was
delighted when I arrived wow we want to
talk to you about that book in more
detail but sadly not today another time
hopefully yeah thanks for having me on